o ato só de quem fala é o dado que sejam
muito bem vindos já mais um vídeo e o
estrago já que clebsch um jeff beck
lurdinha zelamos tribuna que os jogos do
é o sentimento que nós chegaremos aos
300 foquem milton hatoun cuspiu através
simplesmente nós chegaremos aos 300 mil
inscritos e um jato preparar um especial
o vídeo especial para esse acontecimento
especial também é mas vamos vai ter um
cara que o jogo mais esperado do ano que
até se unem e três para a playstation em
cinco embora lá então entende que os
meninos merecem filhos'' usp interna
afirmou do ganho moldes okayo campeã
afirmou que é faca tudo viesse para
investigar um estranhos acontecimentos
na no ano no asae mandou nada saiu como
titular que o hospital como lucas assim
não sai
existem rumores que o chefe está por
detrás destes acontecimentos nestas
coisas estranhas aconteceram encontrar
as oito fotos do gft killer para provar
sua existência e tenta sair bem e vivo
boas arta e sete pontos que os jogos
tempos laender como você tem que
encontrar oito coisas é porque as folhas
para lançarmos de noite ok o eu tenho um
carro aparentemente tem uma antena
consiga ouvir rádio dentro dela
tecnologia sanga não é só sair mesmo não
não não assusta mesmo encontrar uma arma
na casa não quer entrar aqui esta casa é
do demônio em um estaleiro em cima do
que eu alguém a lua melhor textura 2016
porque o jogo vai ser problema aqui a
nosso ver não peça para subir aqui
também estamos ir pro são tão meu deus
theqeel uma cabeça com uma faca espetada
aí eu posso apanhar a faca isso funciona
nada estamos no cs 1.6 vamos pôr
competitivo vamos ganhar dinheiro e
coisas até que as possa fazer com essa
faca é não quero mas eu não gosto mas
porque eu gosto de ver nenhum cuidado
comigo demônios que eu agora tenho uma
faca para desmatar muito adorar este
jogo sério mesmo em portel é aqui o
edital
o game tem braço alguém já que o meu
braço
olha não tenho machado é um facão um
machado na mão e não como é que as
possam entrar aqui tem de apanhar alguma
chapa eu voltei pra casa eu tenho de
encontrar uma chave ou alguma coisa
assim ó ataque cascata ela nossa família
da chave abriu o portão com uma chave
sem fechadura o que eu sei porque o
tenho esta coisa eu nunca nem vida vai
apanhar sabem por quê porque eu tenha
tecla do shift ou não justa com a sejus
pela tua filha pelo funil e tudo isto
por mim e pelo meu trecho após apanhar
aí eu sinto que a pausa do machado
menten 81 vila guaíra
caí e é assim que os porteiros moda foi
esta
no chão manchas na parede não sei que
isto é em média estavam querendo sujo a
cair a porta está fechada encontra uma
chave para abrir eu não sei porque eu
tenho foco em marketing em cima mas
prova lá a sonda indiana jones ainda
lava escorreu vamos fazer racha no jogo
o alerta pouco de sal é aqui ou ainda
porque a sustentar a questão diz tudo
gosta - têm texturas de volta porque
pessoas prontas já morreu
eu não encontrei foto em uma ainda
espera encontrar aqui pelo menos neste
quarto falou fotografias e uma mulher
morta
desculpa lá fora nada de fotografias
ainda
quem não mulher cantar não brunão bebês
em mulheres não uma foto aqui encontrei
o que já tenho uma falta um certa é
estamos já avançaram muito vem
ok não abra vamos embora
não vamos embora que as casas é perigoso
do méxico o peru por aí você vai falar
assim como eu descobri que eu descobri
coloca destas boa não estás porque
queria falar com cadeiras na área
o médico achou que eu tenho uma faca eu
posso apanhar agora é agora sim é
possível apanhar esta coisa que parece é
que os aparelhos para ver o coração os
fones da apple outra que manchava meu
bem eu já achava tão bem escondido aqui
numa ideia é voltar para trás
supostamente eu ponho uma chave que vá
para uma destas portas que estavam aqui
atrás preciso foto guga não não fecha a
porta a porta que eu já vi aquela festa
rock a não achava ser pobre com a não
fez a fotografia ok tá aqui o chefe
embrulhar aquela salsicha etapa do outro
lado aqui temos duas fotos já só faltam
seis já não estava aqui
isto não estava aqui por ser um
salsichas das câmeras porque consegue
vai parecer um barulho extremamente alto
que vai assustar o dia da série o que eu
ganho o jogo a ganhar a porta e sair por
aí pensei ok ok isto num sítio novo no
neo qualquer coisa no meu ouvido - está
aí alguém 11 não quem está aqui uma
temos quatro caixas nos faltam quatro
têm disputado das fotografias é que mete
um funk morto debaixo da camisa 10
ficará a sessão a cair só isso gordo
alguém falou comigo ou nunca vi portas
estão ligadas na minha vida - anda lá
meu porque isso
consegui entrar aqui um deus que ama os
corpos do funk tava com uma fotografia
escondida mesmo como é que é possível
que chefiou do teto não né não o chef
caiu do teto como é possivel lan wan
parkour é que tem que ter alguma página
eu não consegui encontrar o meu está
indo treinar aqui alguma coisa para vez
porque ele fez este jogo está muito bom
ea mãe morreu é sério com fotografia
estava que eu não tinha visto mas não
temos quase a completar o jogo eu acho
não é uma foto uma foto encontrei outro
que tem 17 assuntos falta uma foto em
que o médico vá que os frangos que tem
que fazer agora façam de uma página que
toque tão valioso gdf ok eu vou primeira
fase ainda temos oito conselheiros não
deixa entrar porta e só cai pra mim né
acho que sim parece que eu já fiz aquilo
é real e se o grêmio ainda next chapter
risco
então é isso só vamos ficar por aqui com
este radisson que leve seu gesto que o
word e vários anos para que vocês tenham
estado em breve vai sair se aos
presentes que o script por isso não
percam enquanto não está nesse vídeo vão
se ainda assim este vídeo game celulares
porque senão se esperar até seis desse
período pois você ficou muito tempo sem
vídeos identificar um título chinês a 3
mas pronto os vídeos vão votar a
regularidade agora com esse calor
infernal mas van e isso só quando o
arquivo brito fique mãe e até a próxima